do you think you can be sexy and have
diarrhea at the same time no boy you're
having the diarrhea no I'm here today
with dr. talev who is a poop expert also
known as a gastroenterologist right yes
okay and what does that mean exactly
that's a doctor takes care of people
with problems with their swallowing
their stomach for their guts okay so you
see a lot of poop see how a lot of I
asked my co-workers to send me pictures
of their poop right and they did and it
was so gross that I could not show them
to you it was I I questioned my sanity
looking at my co-workers poop so then
what I had them do was describe them to
an artist who made some artist
renderings and I was wondering if you
could grade the poop absolutely here we
have this one yeah those are little
couple like stories and the reason
they're like that is because the poop is
taking too long to get through the gut
so it's getting dried out so that's a
sign of constipation that's one person
who I guess was constipated so this is a
poop that's not the ideal poop but it's
still within a normal range it's
slightly constipated it's rocks kind of
congregated into a sausage and that's
it's a little more on the constipated
side than a smooth sausage would be the
perfect sausage that's a log that's if
you want a stool that looks like the
ideal poop this is the ideal food this
is it whoever gave me this one I think
it was you you got the perfect poop
that's a green poop so Green is okay
Green is a perfect poop yeah normals
brown green or yellow that's all normal
we got this one that's a mush in your
stool so that looks like it's heading
towards diarrhea with when you're
getting these little flakes that are
kind of watery at the edges so that
suggests you're developing a looser
stool if that's not your normal pattern
and then you have to wonder about
dietary things you might be ingesting
like maybe lactose if you're lactose
intolerant or fructose if you're
fructose intolerant too many dried fruit
too many dried fruits too much fruit
juice all right so that's a very nicely
shaped log with some corn in it that's
perfectly normal
why do we see it why does it just come
of course not well digested it so it
travels through you and that's probably
a good thing it means your transit time
from mouth to the toilet bowl was fast
this is I've not really seen a Mount
Everest looking stool but it looks to me
like this came out more like toothpaste
then again it's a softer story so some
people have have a lute one loose stool
a day and if that's your normal pattern
that can be okay how do you know when
you're having a poop that's like
problematic so you probably should see a
doctor if what you're normally doing
suddenly changes you should see a doctor
if your stools are suddenly coming out
pencils and consistently not one day but
consistently coming out with Ethan or if
it's coming out really funny colors like
pitch black or bloody or white I'm not
afraid to talk about poop you certainly
are not afraid to talk about if it's
your career why do you think people are
so uncomfortable discussing this it's a
mystery to me why people are as jittery
about talking about poop as they are I
think it's because it stinks and people
just don't like talking about bodily
functions that stick